und jetzt das heute journal
[Musik]
heute vor einem jahr der vierzehnte juli
2021 wird für die menschen da nervt und
a zur hölle mit nie dagewesener wucht
rast die flut durch dörfer und städte in
nordrhein-westfalen und rheinland-pfalz
sterben mehr als 180 menschen heute am
ersten jahrestag erinnerung und ein
erneuertes versprechen
heute an diesem tag gedenken würde toten
die opfer bleiben und vergessen wir
trauern gemeinsam
und vereint
und als bundespräsident möchte ich ihnen
sagen sie sind nicht allein
guten abend der bundespräsident auch der
bundeskanzler besuchten heute die
flutgebiete wo die katastrophe an vielen
stellen noch sichtbar ist und präsent in
der erinnerung und der seele der
menschen warum es zu so vielen
todesopfern kam warum zu wenig gewarnt
und evakuiert wurde diese
aufklärungsarbeit läuft und ist längst
nicht beendet heute am ersten jahrestag
stand die anteilnahme im vordergrund für
die betroffenen und die angehörigen der
opfer an seinem stern berichtet
im sommer danach stehen die menschen
zusammen halten sich bei der erinnerung
an die zerstörung die verzweiflung und
den tod erinnerungen an die flut die so
vielen so viel genommen hat vor einem
jahr kämpften sie im aartal ums
überleben während die wassermassen ihre
heimat verwüsteten woran erinnern wir
uns
erinnern uns an das gefühl von den nicht
zu stehen
wir waren fassungslos sprachlos und lena
auch wenn die erschöpfung der letzten
monate noch in den knochen steckt wir
schauen nach vorn wir haben nur diesen
weg auch wenn das wasser so viel schaden
angerichtet hat und wir alle noch lange
mit zeit mit den schäden kämpfen und mit
den erlebnissen verarbeiten müssten habe
ich vom ersten moment an erfahren dürfen
dass menschen in bestimmten situationen
sofort zusammenwachsen
innehalten im kurpark in bad
neuenahr-ahrweiler der kanzler dabei als
stiller teilnehmer das grauen noch so
präsent genau wie die kritik an politik
und verwaltung weil der wiederaufbau
vielerorts quälend lange dauert ich kann
verstehen wenn ihnen alles trotzdem
manchmal nicht schnell genug geht wenn
sie einfach nur wollen dass es vorangeht
und ich versichere ihnen wir arbeiten
jeden tag hart daran dass für alle der
wiederaufbau gut gelingt am 14 juli 2021
kommen bis dahin unvorstellbar große
wassermassen sie reisten brücken
strassen häuser existenzen mit sich hier
im aartal genau wie in nordrhein
westfalen viele verlieren alles viele
verlieren ihr leben gedenken heute auch
in euskirchen
gottesdienst für die die nicht überlebt
haben gemeinsam zurück und nach vorne
schauen immer wieder hört man den dank
von betroffenen an alle die geholfen
haben bevor sich ratlosigkeit breit
macht stehen schon helfende hände dar
ungefragt
unbekannt
ungezählt und unbezahlbar noch er
unbeantwortet die frage was tun damit
sich ein solches flug disaster nicht
wiederholt wie war es möglich wie konnte
das passieren warum wurde nicht schnell
und umfassend genug gewarnt ich glaube
diese frage
müssen wir uns als ganzes land stellen
und auch im namen so viele unserer
landsleute
versichere ich ihnen
sie sind nicht allein
nicht allein in der schrecklichen
erinnerung an die verheerende todes flut
vor genau einem jahr
das ausmaß der flut war ohne beispiel
und auch deshalb wurde die gefahr
unterschätzt wie dramatisch können wir
uns am beispiel von altena anschauen das
vor der katastrophe so aussah der
ortsteil altenburg heute nachmittag
betrug der wasserstand der aare hier 43
cm
43 cm das ist ein normaler mittelwert
vor einem jahr steigt der pegel nach
anhaltendem regen am nachmittag schon
auf anderthalb meter in den abendstunden
dann wird aus hochwasser die katastrophe
bei
82 sind die ersten häuser betroffen die
flut wird reißender bei sechs meter geht
der pegel messer verloren und das wasser
steigt der scheitelpunkt wird in der
nacht bei einer höhe von bis zu zehn
metern 80 erreicht das ist dann
altenburg am 15 juli 2021 ein
jahr danach ist im aartal unglaublich
viel geschafft worden aber es wird noch
lange dauern bis zumindest die
äußerlichen schäden beseitigt sind
christel haas
fertig ist sie noch nicht die weinstube
aber dorothea und benno gilles sehen
licht am ende des tunnels vor einem jahr
stand hier alles unter wasser die beiden
hatten sich ins zweite stockwerk des
hauses geflüchtet und gehofft dass die
flut nicht noch weiter steigt
so sah es bei den winzern vor einem jahr
aus der weinkeller die ferienwohnungen
das eigene heim ruiniert sowie was
10.000 häuser an der seitdem wird wieder
aufgebaut aber es geht quälend langsam
von den 15 milliarden wiederaufbauhilfen
ist erst eine halbe milliarde bewilligt
worden zu bürokratisch zu kompliziert
sagen viele
ja ich habe mal nachgestellt vor einiger
zeit aber
in bearbeitung steht dann am programm
aber ein bisschen schneller können schon
wieder
schneller und vor allem besser wieder
aufbauen das ist das ziel doch experten
üben deutliche kritik
hochwasserschutzkonzept einen echten
plan um jahrhundert fluten besser zu
überstehen die wir es noch nicht wir
müssen wir festhalten dass hier nur ein
zögerliches in einigen bereichen noch
kein wirkliches umdenken stattfindet wir
müssen tatsächlich die
entscheidungsträger die politischen
entscheidungsträger zu einem umdenken
herangeführt werden im aartal und nicht
nur hier brauche es mehr raum für den
fluss mehr rückhaltebecken und weniger
häuser direkt am wasser auch weil wegen
des klimawandels schwere fluten häufiger
und heftiger auftreten könnten ein
wiederaufbau eins zu eins so wie es
vorher war wird keinen sinn ergeben wir
müssen resilient
widerstandsfähiger werden und das heißt
dass wir in allen bereichen der
katastrophenvorsorge mehr investieren
müssen erste schritte dahin sind schon
gemacht beim brückenbau soll es wenn
möglich keine mittelpfeiler mehr geben
sagt der bundesverkehrsminister bei
einem besuch vor ort
denn so schön die alten historischen
arbeiten anzusehen sind oder waren umso
problematischer ist das eben bei diesen
hochwasserereignissen wenn sich dann die
dinge staunen der wiederaufbau schwierig
und zäh winzer gilles muster auch an
sein erspartes damit es vorangeht
weggehen aber ist für ihn ausgeschlossen
soll ich denn jetzt mein ganzes
lebenswerk hier stehen lassen und sie
irgendwohin wo mich keiner kennt naja
ich bleib hier das ahrtal im sommer
danach so wie früher wird es wohl nie
wieder werden
wie früher wird es nicht mehr werden
zu tief der einschnitt denen diese flut
markiert cornelia weigandt war vor einem
jahr bürgermeisterin von altena und ist
seit anfang des jahres landrätin des
kreises ahrweiler schönen guten abend
gute
und danke dass sie sich noch zeit für
uns nehmen sie hatten einen langen tag
haben bei der zentralen gedenkfeier des
landes rheinland-pfalz gesprochen und
haben dabei auch appelliert nach vorne
zu schauen wie schwer fällt das gerade
an einem gedenk tag wie heute ist
überhaupt so etwas wie normalität zurück
an der ahr
ich glaube es gibt tage an manchen ecken
kommt ein wenig normalität aber wir sind
an vielen stellen aufgrund dieser
massiven zerstörung erst am anfang vom
aufbau und ein tag wie heute ist ein tag
zum zum innehalten und zum gedenken der
verstorbenen und an dem tag ist
natürlich der blick nach vorne etwas
schwerer als an anderen tagen das mir
schon hier sie hatten heute hohen
politischen besuch landes und
bundesebene waren vertreten und
dazugehörte ja auch wieder die
zusicherung von solidarität und
unterstützung nun hört man ja immer
wieder klagen dass es so schnell und
unbürokratisch eben nicht geht dass
versicherungen mauern hilfe nicht
ausgezahlt werden wie ist denn ihr
eindruck stimmt der vorwurf die opfer
zumal im aartal würden vergessen an
vielen stellen ist es glaube ich nicht
so schnell wie wir uns das alle wünschen
und es könnte wahrscheinlich an manchen
stellen auch so schneller werden und
insofern es ist einfach ein jahr
vergangen viele sind nicht in ihrem
zuhause und das braucht auch unendlich
kraft das ist sehr zäh dass es kaum
auszuhalten
wir haben glaube ich heute auch ein paar
gute gespräche geführt um vielleicht
auch substanziell noch mal hilfen zu
bekommen etwas beschleunigen zu können
wir werden glaube ich so war die zusage
noch mal 1 baugesetzbuch miteinander
gucken dürfen auch bei dem thema wie
können die betriebe im moment ihr
personal weiter finanzieren da konnten
wir einiges adressieren und wir hoffen
auch so dass in den gesprächen ein paar
gute botschaften möglich gesetzt werden
konnten da gab es signale vom land aber
auch vom bund dass sich da noch etwas
bewegen sollen da hoffen wir jetzt
einfach sehr drauf weil es ist einfach
schwierig ist dauert natürlich lange bei
diesen zerstörungen aber es hat an den
nerven und an vielen stellen hat man
noch die chance etwas zu erreichen
die hilfe ist ja das eine die
konsequenzen aus dem unglück dieser
katastrophe das andere und die werden ja
auch immer noch diskutiert wenn sich
jetzt wieder tagelanger starkregen
ankündigen würde welche wichtigste lehre
haben sie da aus dem letzten jahr
gezogen was muss aus ihrer sicht vor
allem anders laufen in der waren in der
rettungskette das ist nicht ganz einfach
und komplex
wir hoffen natürlich parallel dass wir
nicht passiert wir sind aber auch
hingegangen im frühjahr wo wir schon mal
einen ordentlichen starkregen
angekündigt hatten was noch keine
einsatzlage für uns war unsere
technische einsatzleitung hochzufahren
um tatsächlich unter live bedingungen zu
üben sowohl die technik die
gerätschaften aber vor allen dingen auch
das zusammenspiel mit allen stufen in
der meldekette und das ist aus unserer
sicht gut verlaufen und das gibt uns
eine gute basis und da muss es ja auch
funktionieren das ist ja so der
katastrophenschutz muss vor ort
organisiert werden sind dann auch
ehrenamtliche dabei kommunale beamte
haben sie in den letzten monaten auch
mal den eindruck gewonnen dass
verantwortung da schon ein stück auch
abgeschoben wird denn dies war ja eine
megakatastrophe im gründe die die
kommunale ebene jedenfalls überfordert
hat
wir haben ein ereignis gehabt das war
alles andere als nur kommunal das wasser
fließt den berg runter wir haben zwei
bundesländer betroffen gehabt vier
landkreise unendlich viele kommunen und
wenn sie einen verunfallten sagen wenn
da irgendwann möchte ich auf der straße
liegt ja wenn du keinen notarzt ruft
dann bist du selber schuld das musst du
schon machen das ist ein bisschen
einfaches beispiel aber das macht klar
die situation war ganz extrem und da
muss noch mehr passieren und ich glaube
da wird auch rein geschaut dass kosten
katastrophenschutz muss neu aufgestellt
werden das was wir hatten bis dahin hat
nicht gereicht
natürlich auch ganz klar vor ort einiges
schwierig war und vielleicht defizite da
waren aber das muss auch weiter gefasst
werden man es auch im land und bund
versprechen jetzt mehr verantwortung zu
übernehmen wie lange wird es dauern
frau weigand bis die sichtbaren wohnung
geschlossen sind wenn sie sagen wie ist
die perspektive für styling wie viel
jahren stehen wir wieder aufrecht
ich glaube da gibt es eine mehr zeitig
kite wir haben ja ganz viele provisorien
sind sehr gut intakt also wir haben auch
langzeit provisorien geschaffenen thema
brücken thema schulen mit denen wir erst
mal leben können viele menschen wohl nur
ich sag das wirklich in
anführungsstrichen weil das leid ist
groß genug keller erdgeschoss zerstört
sind die können zum teil jetzt wieder
einziehen sind zum teil eingezogen die
an oder anderen betriebe sind am start
aber wir haben immer noch die situation
ist werden häuser abgerissen wir müssen
große brücken neu bauen wir müssen
schulen neu bauen wir müssen bitte liebe
zum teil neu errichten und einiges von
dem wird auch 35 oder auch zehn jahre
brauchen sagt die landrätin des kreises
ahrweiler hat sich ihnen dank frau
weigand alles gute
vielen dank im dankeschön
das gespräch haben wir am abend
aufgezeichnet die hilfsbereitschaft für
die betroffenen war von beginn an groß
auch auf die aufrufe hier im zdf mehr
als 160 millionen euro sind bis jetzt
gespendet worden wenn sie den menschen
weiter helfen wollen können sie das tun
über das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe iban de 65 104 106 100
104 106 600 stichwort zdf hochwasser
alle informationen wenn sie auch unter
spenden zdf de oder im zdf text auf
seite 8 190
ja jetzt zu weiteren wichtigen meldungen
des tages in moskau soll das russische
parlament morgen zu einer sondersitzung
zusammenkommen huntelaar überraschend
kurzfristig ist diese sondersitzung der
duma anfang der woche einberufen worden
schon heute hat präsident putin ein
gesetz unterzeichnet das der regierung
spezial maßnahmen für militäreinsätze im
ausland erlaubt und mit dem die
russische wirtschaft den krieg
unterstützen sollen in der ukraine sind
bei einem russischen raketenangriff auf
die stadt wien icja fast 20 zivilisten
getötet worden wohn und
verwaltungsgebäude wurden zerstört laut
polizei wurden dutzende menschen schwer
verletzt
die usa und israel haben in einer
gemeinsamen erklärung iran offen mit
gewalt gedroht sollte das land sein
atomprogramm weiter ausbauen beim ersten
israel-besuch von us präsident biden
sagte israels regierungschef la pete
iran könne nur mit einer glaubwürdigen
militärischen drohung vom besitz
nuklearer waffen abgehalten werden biden
betonte zugleich die usa setzten auf
diplomatie und damit auf eine
wiederbelebung des atom abkommens aus
dem die usa unter seinem vorgänger krank
ausgestiegen waren
ohne ergebnis sind in hannover erste
beratungen der spd schiedskommission
über einen möglichen parteiausschluss
von ex kanzler schröder beendet worden
eine entscheidung soll es in den
nächsten drei wochen geben wegen seiner
nähe zu russland waren 17 anträge auf
ein parteiordnungsverfahren
eingegangen schröder war bei den
beratungen heute nicht anwesend und ließ
sich auch nicht vertreten
in baden-württemberg wird die afg jetzt
offiziell vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet innenminister strobl erklärte
der landesverband werde als verdachts
objekt eingestuft die
sicherheitsbehörden des landes seien
hinreichend gewichtige tatsächliche
anhaltspunkte für verfassungsfeindliche
bestrebungen die landesvorsitzende weil
die den posten am wochenende abgeben
will sprach von einem willkürakt und
kündigte juristische schritte an
sri lankas präsident rajapaksa hat unter
dem druck der massenproteste seinen
rücktritt eingereicht per e mail
angenommen wird er sobald das original
schreiben auf dem postweg in colombo
eintrifft rajapaksa war zunächst auf die
malediven und wegen der proteste dort
gegen seine aufnahme weiter nach
singapur geflogen in sri lankas
hauptstadt zogen sich demonstrierende
aus von ihnen besetzten
regierungsgebäuden zurück die proteste
dauern aber an sri lanka erlebt die
schwerste wirtschaftskrise seit
jahrzehnten
italiens ministerpräsident draghi hat
nach wochenlangem streit in der
regierungskoalition seinen rücktritt
eingereicht den staatschef materieller
allerdings nicht angenommen hat zuvor
hatte sich der koalitionspartner fünf
sterne bewegung geweigert einen
gesetzentwurf der regierung im senat zu
unterstützen nach dem abgelehnten
rücktrittsgesuch hat staatspräsident
materieller den parteilosen draghi dazu
aufgefordert dem parlament bericht zu
erstatten und die aktuelle lage zu
bewerten
die regierungskrise in rom ein rücktritt
der nicht angenommen wird da müssen wir
nachfragen bei unserem italien
korrespondent andreas postel brea salou
wie geht das weiter kann sich draghi
halten oder steuert italien auf
neuwahlen zu
aber trainer mario draghi ist bislang
nicht als unverantwortlich bekannt im
gegenteil hat seitdem er hier die
regierung angeführt hat für stabilität
und neues vertrauen gesorgt und deshalb
kann man ein großes fragezeichen daran
machen ob er jetzt italien ob er sein
land in diesen wirtschaftlich
schwierigen zeiten im stich lassen würde
aber es liegt nicht nur an ihm es liegt
an politischen akteuren wie giuseppe
konnte von der 5 sterne bewegung oder
auch matteo salvini von der
rechtsgerichteten lega die profilierungs
druck haben und unter druck in den
eigenen reihen stehen sodass also da
nicht sicher ist wie es da weitergeht
materieller der staatspräsident hat
giuseppe konnte aufgefordert hat mario
draghi aufgefordert sich im parlament zu
erklären und nach neuen lösungen zu
suchen möglicherweise eine regierung
weiterzuführen aber auch neuwahlen im
herbst sind wahrscheinlich das ist alles
nicht ausgeschlossen an diesem tag eines
ist sicher wie auch immer das ausgeht
italiens politische elite hat sich hier
heute nicht mit ruhm bekleckert und es
sich damit wieder einmal treu geblieben
dankeschön andreas postel für die
schnellen einordnungen danke nach rom
drohenden gasknappheit im herbst und
winter beschert uns täglicher
hiobsbotschaften die jüngste kommt vom
chef der bundesnetzagentur
wer die menschen auf eine mögliche
verdreifachung der gasrechnung einstellt
der wirtschaftsminister meint es ernst
mit dem sparen am warmen wasser und die
erneuerung von duschkopf und gastherme
gehört womöglich bald auch zu den
ratschlägen des deutschen kanzlers auch
frankreich muss energie sparen präsident
marco der deutlich mehr hang zum pathos
hat als und ralf scholz nutzt dabei alle
dramatischen mittel die ihm geboten sind
das zeigte sich heute auch am
nationalfeiertag wie thomas walde
beobachtet hat
es ist tradition dass sich die
französische republik am 14 juli feiert
und ihre stärke demonstriert in diesem
jahr scheint diese tradition vielen
schaulustigen
aktueller als zuvor
im zusammenhang mit der ukraine man
dachte oft mit dem krieg wäre es vorbei
aber mit dem krieg ist es nie vorbei
so ein krieg nicht weit von uns entfernt
lässt unser land zusammenrücken
ich denke man muss die ukraine
verteidigen dieser geist marschiert auch
in der parade mit erstmals und ganz vorn
dabei truppen aus osteuropäischen
ländern die die ukraine unterstützen
wir hätten in diesem jahr keine parade
abhalten können die nicht auf die
kriegssituation in europa bezug not und
die reiche symbolik setzt sich fort auf
die osteuropäer folgen französische
einheiten die nach der russischen
aggression gegen die ukraine an die
ostflanke der nato verlegt wurden von
skepsis gegenüber dem bündnis ist schon
lange keine rede mehr stattdessen
schwört der präsident und
oberbefehlshaber der armee die nation
ein
wir müssen unbedingt wieder in all
unsere bestände und kapazitäten
investieren leute einstellen ausbilden
und eine noch stärkere armee haben denn
diejenigen die uns vor einiger zeit
gesagt haben dass es große kriege nicht
mehr geben wird die haben sich geirrt
mit dabei die selbstfahrenden kanonen
vom typ ch die frankreich an die ukraine
liefert man könnte das eine zeitenwende
nennen doch die hatten die franzosen
lange vor ihren deutschen nachbarn nach
den terroranschlägen hierzulande die
zeitenwende hat es in frankreich gegeben
in dem seit mehreren jahren schon das
budget der armee erhöht wurde aber was
wir hier sehen konnten das war die
dramatik des kontextes und vor allem
haben wir vorgeführt bekommen
einheiten waffen die wirklich auf dem
schlachtfeld in
und der präsident versucht diesen geist
weiter zu mobilisieren russland nutzer
gas als waffe meint der soldat makro und
werde die zuvor wahrscheinlich ganz
einstellen mit militärischen worten ruft
er seine landsleute auch auf sich zu
wehren
genial eine generalmobilmachung brauchen
wir wir müssen gemeinsam eine logik der
enthaltsamkeit entwickeln und weniger
energie konsumieren und wissenstest und
großem immer
zu den waffen ruft die marseillais ist
die bürger antreten zum energiesparen
ruft ihr präsident an einem
symbolträchtigen tag schwört emanuel
makro die nation auf entbehrungen und
eine lange auseinandersetzung ein
der krieg und die pandemie belasten die
wirtschaft in der eu die aussichten sind
nicht besonders gut mehr der zugrunde
lag die eu kommission hat in ihrer
sommerprognose die wachstumsaussichten
für das kommende jahr deutlich gesenkt
vor allem auch für deutschland auch
werde die inflation auf historisch hohem
niveau bleiben valerie haller besonders
schlecht im europäischen vergleich ist
die prognose für deutschland warum weil
deutschland erstens sehr abhängig ist
von russischen gas und zweitens eine
besonders energiehungrige industrie hat
also branchen wie chemie metall und
baustoffe die sind einfach stark auf öl
und gas angewiesen und ausreichend
alternativen gibt es noch nicht darum
treffen die hohen energiepreise die
deutsche wirtschaft eben auch besonders
hart die eu-kommission rechnet dieses
jahr für deutschland mit einer
inflationsrate von 7,9 prozent für die
eurozone geht sie von 7,6 prozent aus
ein höchstwert schlechter als der
euroraum soll deutschland dieses jahr
auch beim wachstum abschneiden 1,4
prozent für die eurozone rechnet brüssel
im schnitt noch mit 2,6 prozent wachstum
wie es weitergeht hängt laut eu
kommission stark davon ab wie sich der
krieg weiter entwickelt und natürlich
auch von der energieversorgung schlechte
stimmung an der börse
rezessionsängste treiben die aktionäre
um der dax geht kräftig in die knie
mit fast 2 prozent alle vorhersagen
nicht nur die von der eu kommission
stehen aber unter einem vorbehalt denn
kommt es tatsächlich zum russischen
gas-lieferstopp dann rechnen viele mit
einem kräftigen wirtschaftsabschwung in
europa und in deutschland um es mit den
worten der eu kommission zusagen ein
sturm ist möglich aber so weit sind wir
noch nicht die lage ist ernst vielen
dank valerie nach frankfurt
eine weitere belastung für die weltweit
gestörten lieferketten ist der
warnstreik der hafenarbeiter in den
deutschen seehäfen in dem tarifkonflikt
waren sieben gesprächsrunden bislang
ohne ergebnis bis samstagfrüh wollen die
arbeiter in hamburg und unter anderem in
bremen die arbeit niederlegen bis zu 14
prozent höhere löhne fordert die
gewerkschaft verdi für die 12.000
hafenarbeiter die
stadtverordnetenversammlung von
frankfurt am main hat die abwahl des
umstrittenen oberbürgermeisters peter
feldmann eingeleitet und einem
entsprechenden antrag zugestimmt sollte
fällt man diesen nicht annehmen gibt es
einen bürgerentscheid ab oktober muss
sich der spd politiker wegen
korruptionsvorwürfen die er zurückweist
vor gericht verantworten
in süd europa brechen immer mehr brände
aus wie in spanien frankreich und
kroatien stehen auch in portugal
zahlreiche waldgebiete in flammen
landesweit kämpfen tausende
einsatzkräfte gegen die feuer wie hier
in zentral portugal auch an der algarve
mussten sich viele menschen in
sicherheit bringen temperaturen von über
40 grad und starke winde fachten die
feuer immer wieder an
und noch ein blick auf die königsetappe
der 109 tour de france die der brite
thomas pitt kock gewonnen hat auf dem
legendären schlussanstieg zur alpe
d'huez setzte sich der 22 jährige von
der spitzengruppe ab und sicherte sich
den sieg vor luis manches und chris früh
gesamtführender bleibt der däne diese
letzte alpenetappe gilt als die
schwerste der tour über 165 kilometer
von bremen bis zum berühmtesten radsport
und berg der welt
wir haben diese sendung mit dem
jahrestag der flut begonnen und
empfehlen ihnen jetzt sehr die folgende
dokumentation zu diesem thema dunja
hayali und sarah tacke haben ein jahr
nach der katastrophe betroffene besucht
und helfende und verantwortungsträger
getroffen zwischen wut und mut heißt der
film jetzt
und gegen 0.30 schaut nach entdeckte mir
in unserem heute journal update noch mal
aktuell nach bad neuenahr ahrweiler so
ist es bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend sicherlich haben sie schon
von den waldbränden in südeuropa gehört
die haben inzwischen auch südfrankreich
erreicht hier sehen sie die rauchfahnen
die weit auf den atlantik hinaus reichen
in der nähe von bordeaux bordeaux hatte
heute eine höchsttemperatur von 37 grad
unsere nachttemperaturen sind weit
angenehmer meist liegen sie zwischen 13
und 8 grad und nur am alpenrand und
richtung oberrhein bleibt es bei 17 bis
14 grad etwas milder
über norddeutschland sie viele wolken
hinweg da kann es auch mal ein bisschen
regen geben bei nordwestwind und
einzelne gewitter sind jetzt in der
nacht in niederbayern auch nicht
ausgeschlossen im südwesten ist es
dagegen klar und morgen scheint da
häufig die sonne sonst gibt es viele
wolken und ganz vereinzelt kann es auch
ein bisschen regnen bei nordwesten an
den küsten von nord- und ostsee liegen
die temperaturen morgen bei 18 19 grad
in norddeutschland sind es sonst 19 bis
22 grad im süden 21 bis 26 grad und am
oberrhein geht's morgen 30 grad und dann
wird es von tag zu tag immer wärmer die
größte hitze wird für anfang der
kommenden woche erreicht am dienstag
könnten es am oberrhein sogar 39 grad
werden dahinter steckt das hoch jürgen
das wird sich nämlich in den nächsten
tagen hier über mitteleuropa weiter
richtung mittelmeer verziehen und dieses
tief bringt dann die hitze zu uns für
uns bedeutet das etwas regen vielleicht
am samstag im nordosten in form von
schauern und gewittern und danach immer
höhere temperaturen und nahm